on voudrait la suppression de la tva sur
les produits de première nécessité avait
déjà parlé à l'excellent le plus le plus
cruel qui se fait cesser si c'est d'une
évidence c'est tellement supprime la tva
sur les produits de première nécessité
il faut le faire je suis pression' la
s21 clg pardon pour les petites
retraites voilà
ça c'est des choses que ces gens là où
il ne nous parlait tout le temps de la
même chose là il faudrait qu'il se
pencher là dessus d'accord voilà parce
qu'à bord les musulmans moi je mettrais
le sport tas il me 13 pouces notre vie
ensemble c'est le vivra de sam qu'il
faut souligner mais sinon ça ne sort pas
on voit ce que je crois c'est que ces
jeunes là là les zemmour on fait tous
ceux de ces extrêmes ils vivent pas avec
avec 2 à 3 mais je viens et soul qui
connaissent que ce monsieur a déjà pris
un bus ou un métro oui métro bus et le
métro
très souvent et que je devrais pas le
dire parce que ça rend
le le vide seulement les métros le coc
vide paradoxalement été le meilleur
allié que pouvaient avoir les gilet
jaune pour mettre en avant l'ensemble
des dix cuves des difficultés des
français alors juste une question de
temps je te passe en juste une question
pour les gilet jaune que d'une vraie
question gilet jaune ah qu'est-ce qu'on
fait de notre argent en termes d'impôts
voilà qu'est ce qu'on fait du rds pour
qu'aujourd'hui l'hôpital soit dans un
état pareil qu'est ce qu'on fait
aujourd'hui à nous augmenter les impôts
beaucoup quand on arrive à la préfecture
on puisse même pas avoir une personne
qui nous rend service et nous donne
notre permis qu'est ce qu'on fait de
notre argent ça c'est une question gilet
jaune ça n'est pas retenue doit
justifier notre argent pour pouvoir
payer des impôts quand on va faire des
courses on justifie notre action en
argent je leur viande l'avait dit le dos
avec le député à faire croire que tout
est gratuit non on le paye qu'est ce
qu'on fait de nos travaux mais je
vous raterez tous les jours et tous les
mois et où les armes en 2006 a été
retiré par monsieur de villepin qui soit
disant pour renflouer les caisses de
l'état et s'est dite fière moi j'ai une
idée on va aux mamans dans les halls et
désordonnés les péages on va vendre les
péages alors que cet argent c'était pour
les hôpitaux c'était pour les écoles
c'était pour les cantines hat a donné
aux airs et polsat ou m'écouter c'est
pour les quartiers les maisons de
retraite c'était pour le français
gasquet pour le phrasé de toutes les
classes c'est une mafia n'est pas
responsable de tout ce qui se passe je
tiens à dire
vraiment la moitié
non mais voilà voilà qu'il faut
renationaliser les autres des autoroutes
ça si c'est important aussi
une chose qui en fait c'est tout du bien
vivre ça c'est tout le mieux vivre on
veut du mieux vivre alors c'est pas plus
de 25 élèves dans les classes pouvoir
d'achat le saurai chat c'est bien de ce
que nos amis fans moi ma fille elle
était c'est pas vous comment sont vos
enfants mais l'était ma petite que j'ai
fait le bisou un seul lycée qu'elle doit
être fait en train de faire dodo longues
années je t'aime fort en thème
l'été il transpire nos enfants un peu en
paix dans l'école c'est pas normal ça
c'est pas normal ça si si c'est pas
possible tu ramènes et tu vas chercher
ton petit alors ça va elle un peu plus
le petit copain me tue qui l'apprennent
à l'école comme il faut ces six là déjà
ça va pas ils ont un concept une idée
fait mes enfants il faut prendre soin
faut pas nos soins après les médias 31
avant d'être dans des classes entre
n'est sûr que ça part en vrille bien sûr
que ça ça peut pas aller ça ne peut pas
aller après qu'est ce que vous avez fait
vous avez mis des gens d'être détour des
cages à poules et vous attendez-vous de
50 ans optez ça va pas aussi le bord de
l'eau
c'est le bordel on dirait que pagnol
[Applaudissements]
d'ailleurs c'est pas vrai parce qu'il ya
des braves à jeanne ya beaucoup de
familles et voilà mais vous vous êtes là
on peut plus elle ment on est tellement
considérés comme des petites gens par
une frange de la société et qu'on
appelle les élites et ça devient un
support il faut être autant dénigrer
ont été traitées d'analphabètes de 2 2 2
si si on n'était pas un alphabet ton
était antisémite moi je suis un islamo
gauche au pilon d'un cheveu en fashion
barbe on a été on a été un vrai musulman
j'ai pas du tout la barbade aruba 2h et
moi j'ai une liste doit être propre tour
de la région la faute voilà met donc à
un moment donné mais pour faire pour
faire simple le vrai débat sur internet
trouver le vrai débat vous avez sans une
revendication qui ont été mis en place
par 1,5 million de francs c'est encore
plus fort que le grand débat de macron à
l'époque simple clair net et précis on
parle d'achats le pouvoir d'achat c'est
un concept marketing qui vous fera
acheter des téléphones et des
téléviseurs d'accord on parle du
mieux-vivre emmener notre famille
jusqu'à la fin du mois faire bénéficier
d'un petit cinéma à nos enfants quelque
peu parce qu'on parle du passé ni terre
qui nous prive de nos libertés mais tant
qu'à faire les gilet jaune ils se paient
pas plus un cinéma avant le pass and i
ter est juste parce que moi le pass
annie terre ça nous a bien amusé pendant
l'été certes mais à un moment donné sans
qu'une tape à plus de liberté
aujourd'hui donc rétabli sont
aujourd'hui les finances des français
pour pouvoir aussi leur libérer de
l'espace dans leur cerveau pendant
qu'ils sont en train de remplir leur
vente pour pouvoir justement apprendre à
vivre ensemble apprendre de la part des
uns et des autres parce qu'aujourd'hui
les gens sont juste concentré je le
répète à rembourser la bagnole qui leur
sert à les amener au travail j'ai tout
simplement des revendications
démocratiques parce que je crois que
l'une des surprises de total de l'élite
pendant le mouvement des jets les jeunes
ça a été l'émanation de cette
revendication numérique on ne passe que
non non non non non non le riz sur le
ring tu vois je vais être honnête parce
que c'est ce que je dis sur les ronds
points pour un mouvement qui voulait pas
être récupérée politiquement la première
récupération des gilets jaunes
telluriques on aime ou on aime pas j'ai
pas forcément d'avis là dessus je me
plie à la majorité les gilet jaune
d'ordre général demande une démocratie
directe de pouvoir ne pas leur demander
leurs voix tous les cinq ans pour qu'ils
puissent faire mutiler quand une fois
qu'ils vont gueuler quand ils sont pas
contents et que quand cette voie ils
l'ont donné complices aussi leur
demandez peut-être tous les jours sur
des décisions importantes qui les
concernent directement aujourd'hui on va
prendre des décisions sur le monde du
travail face à des mecs ont jamais mis
le pied au boulot pour la majorité
d'entre eux on n'est pas cohérent elle
et doit être évoqué les élus par exemple
je vais bien aujourd'hui on en revient
toujours au même problème si toi tu fais
une connerie alors fait virer
immédiatement d'al gore comme un
chauffeur de taxi qui écrase un minot il
perd son permis un homme politique qui
fait mal son boulot qui met aujourd'hui
les français dans le comment on peut
faire confiance à un autre ancien
premier ministre qui aujourd'hui est à
rappeler à l'ordre parce qu'il sait même
pas gérer sa ville et on est là en train
de voter qu'on sait jean la moyenne tout
que des fois je ne comprends pas ce
chaînon nasri joue peut s'exprimer quand
j'entends hâtif chef des fouilles attend
juste à défaut des verts et les français
on a essayé de mettre en place des
alertes depuis trois ans aujourd'hui les
a là les alertes et clignote dans tous
les sens et tout va bien mais vous en
mourrez le garçon me dit vous alors
léger léger ou ne vous ai posé la
question de savoir pourquoi les français
en fait ça les intéresse pas ce que vous
racontez vous raconter parce qu'il
prétend
aujourd'hui ont lancé aujourd'hui on
leur serre sont des plateaux télé que
des gens comme vous qui parle de sujets
qui va bientôt
je les prends
aujourd'hui
on apprend cette idée reçue en vente du
je suis fatigué aujourd'hui de chauffe
de se préciser ce prêt si vous ressentez
vous à long terme avait en son temps
messieurs vous ajoutez des amériques à
un moment donné je suis désolé je ne
savais pas ça je suis fatigué a través
mission c'est je finis l'affût je suis
fatigué de ce foutu préfixe re les gilet
jaune sont de retour reviennent repense
on allait jouer le retour on est là
depuis 150 actes d'accord on est là
depuis 150 acton et ça me dit on est
dans la rue on est sur les ronds points
c'est juste le gouvernement et les
médias qui ont voulu nous faisait face
et
vous n'avez aucun respect pour 12
ouvrages aucun respect aucun respect
pour disent ils et cherche à s'exprimer
depuis dix minutes importance comme
garmin est et c'est faisable à tous à
dire qu'il est encore cette page la
dernière mesure ce qu'est ce qui me
paraît maintenant j'ai fait très vite
départ à la retraite à 55 ans mais c'est
un peu jeune mais bon les métiers à fort
à forte pénibilité
nationale aberration
arrêtez de vous [ __ ] de moi parce
qu'il ya déjà
monté un peu aussi faut arrêter ce fonds
d'1 minute non mais je souris non
malheureusement
je veux dire c'est qu'il ya des gens qui
souffrent oui mais
même cadence on pouvait regretter dans
des trucs en faire montceau n'ai pas
d'amis ils m'en ont dit que vous avez
une méconnaissance des mêmes jeux
l'humour ça
on
connaissait pas je n'ai jamais vu aux
manifs l'on sait bien avec moi personne
mais je suis déjà
arrivés tous les deux et le beauf là
j'apprends toujours contre les mêmes
personnes ça n'est pas de la démagogie
est invité en mai chez roma
connaît rien
samedi en effet par tous comme moi
c'était très bon samedi tout j ai jamais
ça suffit que c'était son manifeste le
samedi c'est dérangeant très bien en ce
moment mais je de respect zizou nom est
lui toujours sur place aux deux services
annoncés pendant des années sans ce soir
et zizou je précise que l'humour c'est
une forme de respect c'est tout ce que
c'est bon je suis le premier clown et ya
pas de propos que je respecte et je me
sens avec un propos comme en a pas tant
de détails et ou est ce qu'on trouve
l'ensemble des propositions du gilet
jaune le vrai débat sur jérôme rodriguez
page officielle sur fly rider maxi
nicole je demande à savoir il ya
énormément de sites douteux de gilet
jaune où tu as toutes les revendications
du peuple et je vais maintenant que les
pensées les gilets jaunes ce que je fais
est revenu sur ce sujet pour vous
souhaitez laisser le par les censeurs ça
me ferait bien c'est que des charges
patronales n'est pas trompé trop de
charges ils ne peuvent pas embaucher
seront pas
les patrons n'est pas pareil le joint
moria décrire les matrones
je m'en fous
il faut qu'ils ont dû se payer des blues
de st c'est là les mecs ils gardent avec
l'industrie femme avait un prix qui paie
des impôts ok je peux finir une salle
sans même la terre si tu mens comme tu
le savais
je les achète si on achète
il faut faire il faut faire du travail
il faut faire du travail je sais pas si
il a fait l'ena si j'allais là ils ont
ils ont fait des grands des études mais
ces choses là c'est pas chasser peuvent
se rassembler autour d'une table on en a
marre on va recommencer la même pour
finir
ce qu'on est en train de vous dire il
fait tout ça tout ça si pour vous dire
que vous l'avez sur internet mais si ça
continue
ici on fait que manger des restes des
miettes le 18 mois on continue un gros
voilà un gros appel est lancé pour
samedi sur un reprise des ronds points
pour montrer qu'on est bel et bien
visible si on a mis un gilet jaune
c'était pour être visible et non pas
pour se faire shooter parfait parce qu'à
défaut de tuer la police moi je peux te
dire qu'elle nous protège voilà
[Applaudissements]